[Music]
[ __ ] the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm up in our Hey oh my god thanks
for coming out ladies and gentlemen we
are here at the scum and villainy
canteen on Hollywood Boulevard in
Hollywood California not Hollywood
Florida
put your hands he goes to the folks at
home know that you're real when last we
gathered ladies and gentlemen I was an
immature 48 today I am a few days past
my birthday so I stand before you a 49
is the final year of my 40s wow I don't
get it again nope no and you're younger
than me right I'm by a year yeah [ __ ] I
hit 50 before you I'm gonna see if I can
catch up though do all you can I feel
like we need to commemorate this
birthday that we all sort of missed in
what way happy birthday to you nobody
sang it happy birthday to
my first of the you happy birthday dear
Kevin Smith happy birthday
[Applause]
[Applause]
jaesi I apologize for all the glasses
that mark broke with hitting that high
note Pavarotti dear Anu you can belt it
out give it up for Margot strong so what
did you do for your birthday
not much nothing really like League I
hiked Runyon and then me and Jennifer
went out for falafel and then she was
like vegan celebrations Missy it was
panic and then she was like I'll do
anything you want what do you want to do
for your birthday and I was like I want
you to watch endgame with me
cuz she wouldn't do it prior to that
she's like that's long she wouldn't go
to the theaters to see and stuff she's
like three hours I'll watch it when it's
home and so I told her when it came out
I was like well you can watch it she's
like whatever I'll catch up to it so I
was like this is what I want for my
birthday
[ __ ] watch endgame with me and you
can't be on your computer while it's
happening have to sit next to me on the
bed and focus on the movie ask questions
about characters you don't know and
tolerate all my Marvel splaining along
the way and she was like fine it's your
birthday and she was so compliant that
like halfway through the movie I was
like I should have [ __ ] asked for sex
man like the [ __ ] did I go for endgame
and [ __ ] but it was cool man at the end
of it she was like you know what that
was really good I was like right [ __ ]
brilliant she goes it's good let's leave
it there joining the rest of the human
race has already seen that movie [ __ ]
works man works like crazy and [ __ ] and
she got to see me cry all over it and
whatnot she kept looking at me cuz I was
like she leans back and watches the
movie like playing against the headboard
with her back against a headboard like
this and I lay on my stomach looking at
the TV like that so periodically like I
would vibrate from her point of view and
she said like I don't know if that
vibration is laughter or tears with you
and [ __ ] and I was like this movie is so
good it's [ __ ] bull watch his pretty
sweet so we did that and then I got on a
plane the next day went to Jersey and we
did a script reading of clerks three the
movie that we never made years ago and
it was a benefit for the first Avenue
Playhouse which is a little dessert
theater in Atlantic islands New Jersey
where we held auditions for clerks 26
years ago so they've fallen on a little
bit of financial hard time so we threw
together this benefit and we you know we
didn't know if anyone would go for it we
put up tickets for like a hundred bucks
there were only 80 seats it sold out so
fast we added another screening that
sold out and stuff so we raised between
the tickets and the prints that we made
for the theater and sign 20 grand for
them which is very very cool Jamie was
there Jamie came out and stuff
representing there's so weird I felt
like I was stoned because I was like I
just saw you back West and there she was
baggy but it was a trip because nobody
only very few people had ever even read
that script so to read it out loud was
like I got to see if it worked finally
and it did like you know it was funny
but it's a [ __ ] depressing screenplay
the guy who wrote clerks three forgot
that it's a sequel to a comedy so he was
real like
it's real like if Clark's was me and my
life in my 20s and clerks 3 was life in
my 30s the clerk's to is life in my 30
clerks 3 was kind of me and my 40s mid
life to the end it was very obsessed
with death and then I almost died years
later and I was like oh now I know what
real despair is like so I don't want to
make that movie anymore thank God we
didn't when we did it's not like it's
bad it actually kind of works it's like
the King Lear of USQ movies it's so
[ __ ] epic but it's just not the way I
should end up with those characters I
have a better clerks three that I think
I want to write instead so but it was
awesome reading it for the crowd man you
know I figured like aw it's like a
hundred and ten page script there
actually was like a hundred and eight so
I figured we'd be done with the reading
I'm like two hours tops first night was
three hours and change second matinee
which was the next day was four hours
when all was said and done just kept
[ __ ] stretching and stretching and
stuff so I got to read Randall
which you know was the role that I wrote
for myself years ago that's why he's got
all the best jokes but didn't want end
up playing the role because I was not
confident as an actor and I was like let
me take a role there has no dialogue and
that was Silent Bob so for this I've
read the Randall Park Brian Oliver and
read Dante I also read J which was
[ __ ] weird and then read Silent Bob
they didn't have anything to say so that
was kind of easy it was it was awesome
and I've never done that before like
read one of my scripts we did a reading
once of a script that I wrote with Annie
McHale first called the intelligence
thank you at The Improv but we never
read one of my scripts out loud and it
was it was cool like I enjoyed the
experience we'll probably go back and do
it again because their goal was to have
50,000 so I'm like oh we could do like
three more shows and they'll be there
and stuff and I enjoyed doing it so much
so we'll do that a couple more times
before it's done so then I came back
here and I had
it's like adventure this morning like I
I want walking like I do Runyon Canyon
all the time and I bring Shecky with me
and Chucky is my fifth 14 almost 15 year
old miniature dachshund she's got a lot
of [ __ ] energy and she's always up my
ass which sounds way dirtier than I mean
it and [ __ ] she's always like take me
out take me out and we're used to
walking this little hill by my house
instead this is good enough it's like a
mile up and back but I've taken to going
to Runyon which at first she was all
about and chicks there's other dogs she
likes to fight and stuff so but now you
know I guess she's starting to feel her
age cuz like will get not even halfway
up running and she just [ __ ] stops
just shuts down and stands there looking
at me like you're [ __ ] serious about
this so then like you know I'll be like
come on Jackie come on and then Jill
[ __ ] it and go a little bit further and
then she [ __ ] stops again and then I
wind up picking her up and carrying her
and show like that so it's really ER
take and then I yell at her it'll whole
[ __ ] walk up from like you wanted to
come you know people looking at me like
he's one of those people that insist the
dog knows what he's talking about is
here so generally when I walk up Runyon
was Chucky I get to the top and then I
call a lift or an uber and take that
home because the hard part the real work
out is going up Runyon Canyon going down
run again and it's just gonna be
terrible on my 49 year old knees so
instead and also I got [ __ ] to do I mean
it's something that it's like an hour
and change get up [ __ ] running again
and [ __ ] the hour walking home so
generally I get up there I'm hiking all
wrong yes
clearly it's I can't wait I can get a
ride at the end of this [ __ ] yeah man I
once I figured that [ __ ] out I'm like oh
there's an app for that
so I generally get picked up walked down
today schecky was particularly [ __ ]
belligerent about just stopping cold
like you know normally I could be like
come on and [ __ ] like talker and oh
come on check if we gotta go but this
time she was having none of it and she
just [ __ ] stopped and [ __ ] so I
carried her up most two running which is
a real [ __ ] [ __ ] like it and like
cuz I'm like this is for me not for you
like why do you have to ruin
everything for me and she's not even
paying attention she's just looking at
other dogs from a different vantage
point normally she's so close to the
[ __ ] ground all she sees her like
balls and [ __ ] and [ __ ] but in my
arms she's like holy [ __ ] I'm lording
over all these [ __ ] man as we got to
the top and I want to get my normal like
lyft or uber home and I couldn't get one
nobody would [ __ ] come up it was like
20 minutes I'm like 20 minutes I could
walk home faster than [ __ ] but that'd be
bad on the knees so I was calling my
wife you know because very rarely do I
ever bug her to come get me in [ __ ] but
I start blowing her up and she didn't
answer she didn't answer her phone or
cell then I called the house line she
didn't answer and [ __ ] and you know I
start getting surly where I'm like what
the [ __ ] I had a heart attack once you
know you should be standing by the phone
in case some getting all [ __ ] is I'm
walking home carrying this [ __ ] dog
and so like getting ready to fight with
my wife like how dare you and [ __ ] and I
didn't like notice but a car stopped in
front of me and step and a person got
out and they were walking on my side of
the road toward me and I'm walking on
the shoulder up on Mulholland Drive
so I you know I'm [ __ ] wrapped up I
got music going and [ __ ] and I'm got the
dog and I'm wrapped up and my [ __ ]
like how do I win this fight when I get
home pre plotting all my arguments and
[ __ ] so that when I get there she'll
have no room no quarter and I'll win
because that's marriage and and then all
of a sudden this dude like comes
face-to-face with me and stops and he
goes a Kevin and I was like I'm just not
used to that because I wasn't expecting
somebody to like stop me and talking so
hey and but the dude spoke he had a
British accent oh yeah suddenly all
classy and [ __ ] it was like hey man like
I just like we're here visiting from
overseas and like we're driving and like
you're just walking here and stuff and I
was like I am
and then instantly I go can you give me
a ride home you [ __ ] an itch hiked
down from the top of Runyon and I was
like yeah yeah I guess yeah come on
and so I'll suck your dick for a ride oh
I was so close man I was like I'll do
Wiener tricks and I was holding a wiener
so I'm going to the car and you know
it's clearly they've rented it he's
there with the lady his partner and the
you know first thing I think is oh [ __ ]
they've rented a sports car there's no
back seat to speak of so they're comfy
in the front seat and the passenger seat
but the back seat is like was it a
Mustang I don't know what it was one of
those sporty one of those very tiny to
get in the back so much so that I was
almost like oh [ __ ] I have to pass up on
the ride or I have to ask his lady
friend to get into the [ __ ] back of
the car which I'm sure like she would
have been like what the [ __ ] is going on
man
so I say you know what I'll go for it
I'll try to get in the back and stuff
and I'm clutching checky like a football
mind you I still got her and getting
into the back end it was tight and so
tight that when my man got into the car
to drive I was like you're gonna have to
pull your seat up you know which if I
was him I'd have been like [ __ ] you you
the one that needs the right man so we
drove home to my house and [ __ ] I'll go
down the hill and get to my place and
stuff and I was like you guys want to
take a picture man come on let's get car
we'll take a picture and then I was like
you know what just come in the house the
Lighting's better and
just a very elaborate reverse kidnapping
so uh okay we're gonna do is and we have
the dog right you get off a man I can't
walk anymore I'm gonna find somebody
with a rental car that's cool coo coo
coo coo I got this I got this
hey Mikey give me rides could be really
take the backseat but it sorry I gotta
go down the pictures cool yang don't you
come in the house when you come to the
house hey now does not a bear cage to
worry about it to worry about just get a
[ __ ] cage it's cool it's cool
what was I on cocaine that was Michael
Pena playing you reverse kidnapping
somebody and then telling his friends
about it I am oh my god now I think
about it like like they're over from
overseas they don't know they could have
just literally disappeared in the bowels
of my house and no one would suspect me
of all people and [ __ ] like that be nuts
I hadn't thought about that I never
think about killing people mark so they
came in and I was like we took pictures
and then I was like you know do you want
a drink and they were lecture and then I
was like all right and I wanted to go
get him a drink which is like I have to
go upstairs but then I was like oh [ __ ]
it just let's all go and so we all went
upstairs to my office and [ __ ] and then
you know I had a lot of stuff like hey
man you want a free hat hey man you want
you want me to sign a hit girl trade
paperback to you and stuff and then
ultimately I was like hey man do you
want one of these jerseys and I signed a
Jersey for him because [ __ ] is
my hero yeah he had to like walk home
what's your blood type
only thing I didn't offer and I should
have was [ __ ] weed cuz I had lots of
that and [ __ ] so we you know they told
me where this is really weird and
surreal because we're gonna go see you
tonight at your show at the cantina
so my heroes are here tonight where are
you guys man
there they are right
[Applause]
jccc you got you got a microphone real
quick we just hit him with throw them up
here by the wall I'm so glad he didn't
kill you
it was so like delight you gotta come up
here doing so everyone can see it
I have everyone at home it was from the
UK didn't forget his pint a big
adventure man what's your name Chris
Chris everyone give it up for super
crisp
[Applause]
fairly accurate telling of the story so
it was it a fairly accurate telling of
the story yeah pretty much
now do your version like how the [ __ ]
why did you stop what were you doing up
there
so we number one before you jump in here
story he were you from and England okay
see if you won't even tell us a town but
he's from you invited him into your
house yeah so circumspect with the
details over there for those that don't
know this or ever watch a movie or TV
the driving is different the steering
wheels on the complete other side of the
car and you drive on a complete other
side of the road every time I go to
England and I think about maybe I'll try
driving here one day I will sit behind
somebody who's driving me and by the
time we go to wherever we're gone I'm
like I would have killed us eight times
so I'm glad I don't do it but Chris
rented a [ __ ] American car and like
went for it man and not only went for it
but like if you're not from Los Angeles
it's the worst [ __ ] place in the
world to drive I mean thing and the only
reason I could drive here is because I
learned to drive in New Jersey and
that's like being forged in a [ __ ]
room you know steal [ __ ] you know how to
[ __ ] Drive but and New York as well
totally if you could drive in New York
could drive anywhere in the world but
this is a tricky [ __ ] city to drive
in man and there they were driving up on
Mulholland [ __ ] shocked that they didn't
just go boom right off Mulholland Drive
so what was the deal how did we meet
from your perspective yeah so it's you
meet your hero and all you do is talk
about driving down a road you know it's
like do we did have a gun up in our
Central Station not bad but it was no I
was out a pretty pleasant perfectly
Pleasant but it's just like a yeah and
it was like wow it's quite windy around
here like eh yeah but it's in England
the roads are quite windy so that's fine
you know cars quite big but you know we
handle it and that's it
the conversation just just very banal
but quite pleasant you know what was the
whoa
what were you doing up at my house and I
just wanted to drive from Holland you
know it's quiet connect beautiful up
there
yeah yeah it's amazing and after we
dropped you off we pulled into like a an
overlook and took some photos that was
really nice but yes and you guys went
back out look let's find other directors
body looks like Quentin Tarantino well
it was just we cuz it just came to like
a conversation about fades because we're
like a well if we had done this and
because to get to this point we had to
bypass a car crash hope that person
lived because you know oops and then you
know and then go down this way but we
didn't get done that we went that way
and yeah there's quite a few
it was [ __ ] sliding doors
without Gwyneth Paltrow yeah yeah yeah
they might have her head in a box in the
trunk oh my god sliding seven doors then
yeah it's just and then like an hour
later kind of hit me a bit I was like oh
[ __ ] like did I take advance the
situation which I should've no no no no
you're like ah [ __ ] I should have asked
him for weed did you notice the smell of
weed when he came and asked oh yeah on
Genoa
and that is what's beautiful about that
is I hadn't been home in over an hour at
the house and nobody else smokes weed in
the house so it's still reeks of weed
it's not weed in the woods in front of
you like the Pigpen of weed just like
weed clouds gonna I'm sure the cars
public I've already been to dispensary
as well like yeah yeah really
interesting like cuz I've been to like
I'm stem and that's kind of shitty like
it's very like it's classless so you
just got glassless yeah they really got
I hate to think about what you guys said
about me when you got back to your car
he's [ __ ] classless squeeze his fat
ass in the backseat and beg for a ride
so I'm stem is very much like and they
play on the stereotype of like 20 years
ago it's like hey hey guys you remember
Bob Marley and you go like yeah from
four years ago yeah he look sweet want
some wheat and I gave it and all right
yeah maybe their money to be fair I'm
the guy that's like hey remember James
hahaha yeah you could kill an Amsterdam
he's gonna change the [ __ ] game
that's true man they might have just
heard about those characters I never be
against like a dispensary in LA and it's
just like way to remember doctors it's
like a GP in England so you're like
getting what's your name Chris good to
you first time yep print it you sit
there and then you know they call your
name you go down there you ask some
questions they give you some weed and
[Laughter]
it was it was very fortuitous man you
guys made my morning and you made the
top of the show man congratulate you
Chris Chris what's your lady's name was
your lady's name Helen Helen everyone
give it up for Ellen she was there as
well weird wonderful world man it really
is I did not kidnap a bunch of UK
citizens from the backseat of their car
yeah this morning but what you do
instead uh I mean I've been watching
[ __ ] like my mom was in town for like
ten days
Oh which which is lovely and wonderful
except that like I'm then like tourist
tour guide for like ten days and this is
you're like six visit out here so we've
seen [ __ ] everything it's not a
matter of like squeezing hey mom did you
ever go to Pasadena yeah but four times
but like pretend you didn't like let's
go find some just drive around for a bit
so I was able to catch up with a bunch
of [ __ ] that I missed while mom was here
my favorite of them was I got to show my
son Terminator in Terminator 2 which he
had never seen before okay how does it
play for a modern kid um the first one
he was like the music is weird I'm like
I know it got made out of [ __ ] Casio
he's like these special effects are kind
of odd I'm like I know he made the movie
for like four million dollars like for
that it's pretty amazing and so he got a
road within understood it he we dug it
and then we watched her made her - and I
forgot that you don't like I've lived
with the twist of that movie for so long
I just consider it like read like we all
know that spoilers Arnold Schwarzenegger
is the good guy but if you had never
seen Terminator before and then you
watch it and then he was Terminator -
that twist lands like a [ __ ] anvil of
oh [ __ ] he's the good guy
oh that's the [ __ ] bad guy I don't
know which way is up anymore and it's I
remember that
matters where you're like oh my god I
know oh my god he's got roses
oh my god he's got a gun oh my god this
is sweet child him yeah welcome to the
jungle but it was so amazing when he
turned out to be the [ __ ] good guy
yeah what cuz they didn't really I don't
know if they even spoiled that in the
trail humming they did I think they were
very careful about that and and a decent
chunk of that movie was shot in not just
Southern California but the valley and
so the mall that the you know the
[ __ ] arcade is is the North Ridge
fashion Center which after that got hit
by the giant earthquake and collapse and
they rebuilt and now we live like ten
minutes from there isn't that the
Fashion Square Mall that [ __ ] mall
that's unlike Riverside no no it's the
something Northridge is further Oh in
Northridge yeah and like all of the
[ __ ] like the LA River chase stuff is
shot like in streets by my house so it's
super weird to be like a New Yorker who
has seen that movie a thousand times and
then find out that you live within
spitting distance of like half of that
same but hey buddy that's that's really
right there that's Heyman Hurst
there's lassen there's that he's like
this is cool so that was that was super
fun to get awesome to know that it still
works - I know like we just take it for
granted because it was like so long ago
but yeah yeah he's just got frozen the
movies over right nah son and I got to
say that like not even [ __ ] like
ironically just nah son it's not over
there's more to come my son how awesome
man I did a viewing of labyrinth with my
kid I think I talked about it recently
like within the last month I was like
let's watch labyrinth something I'd
always meant to do with her and she just
turned 20 and I think I was about 15
years too late too
the movie still works but the whole time
she was just like you sure this is the
one you wanted to watch again man
[ __ ] lament Bowie's in it [ __ ] not
Pan's Labyrinth no no no no but then
when I was on the I am d boat at
comic-con I was interviewing the cast of
snow catcher they're doing that as a
series it's no Pearson snowpiercer
and Jennifer Connelly's in it and so I
was talking to her interviewing her and
she's given a response to something
about snowpiercer
and I like had a stoner moment where
finally she stopped speaking I was like
I'm sorry man I phased out cuz all I
could think about is you're the little
girl from opera man yeah it's kind of
strange in any event so what else did
you watch i watched the boys i've seen
the first step for besides of the boys
yeah so [ __ ] good yeah like like I'm
gonna say surprisingly good because I
had kind of low expectations going in
why it's got a pretty good pedigree our
Dennis book itself you've got Seth and
Evan and you've got crib totally but
it's like we're living in this wave of
the kind of postmodern commentary on
superhero dumb right itself between like
Doom Patrol and Umbrella Academy and now
the boys and you just feel like a cycle
of similar if not the same right and I
was just kind of like blown away with
not just how seriously they're taking it
but how inspired they're taking it and
how they're playing so fair does it
deviate a lot from the book I can't be
sure I don't know how it ends yet okay
I've been told by trusted sources that
it does deviate a little bit from the
sort of finale of the first trade in the
first like story thrust of the book
right but not in any way that feels like
out of place but how's Carl the Carl's
great like he's having so much [ __ ]
fine he's so good man he's like and
everything he was an amazing Judge Dredd
not to mention he's a great [ __ ] ball
and remember him as ravager Van ronk as
well he's I've interviewed him a couple
times he's nice too man he's a nice dude
he's funnier than he's ever really let
you know let out of a box on screen
except here like he's just doing it and
I'm so taken with home Lander as a
character because Superman would
absolutely be a sociopath and that is
what the boys is doing and like because
if you were a God among people and let's
pretend you might not have been raised
by the two greatest people on the face
of the planet right and you just have
like oh no a bug and it depends what
incarnations you call them greatest
people one version of the guys like
don't save me save the dog some would
say that's a better person than the
other ones no it's true but yeah just
the fact that that's a dude who will
gleefully let people die because they
don't mean anything to him maybe there's
the human the human person is a speck on
the windshield of the home lenders life
what did that you say that this just
happened this photo and you slipped I
had a [ __ ] like Twilight Zone moment
where I was like they've captured me
mark what technology you have you know
it's like a [ __ ] Polaroid's
wait you were fast you were sneaky man
that was good
not well but but I can kind of tell it's
me that's why I was kind of freaked out
right I mean you wouldn't get like the
the traffic ticket from that we dismiss
at the court like we can't be sure that
that's you mr. Smith true I'm like sway
too blurry man could be Kevin James
[Applause]
but yes you should totally check out the
boys I'm kind of in love with I watched
episode one and liked how deeper you I'm
for in oh [ __ ] I'm enough to see how
they deal with aquatic mammals it's oh
damn like it's you get there you'll get
there and it's worth it when you get
there because then you're like oh this
is a show that's gonna do that now
alright it reminds me of honestly Garth
Ennis is hit man run where he comes up
with an excuse to kill baby seals right
it's one of those like no I see how this
works I see what you're trying to do
take the sweetest animal and then do
things to it he's so good I saw the
first episode of pennyworth oh [ __ ]
how is it did anybody know that there
was a penny worth show there seemed like
shock and awe when it's a penny worth it
was one of those shows that when they
announced it it was like what why why
they offered show but the trailer is
actually [ __ ] goodly it looks pretty
great i I don't understand when it's set
because you know coming into you know
it's Alfred before he became the Wayne's
Butler so clearly it's like 1960s 1970s
London but there's like dirigibles in it
and like horse-drawn buggies and
convertible cars and like when is this
supposed to be like how does this slot
in because we come to it is like oh this
is before that like Bruce Wayne isn't
born yet
so this is a time in a place that really
existed but it sounds like they've
pulled from a lot of different versions
of Gotham like including Batman the
Animated Series they always had [ __ ]
dividual it is except this is in London
so it's like what and then like they do
the thing where he meets Thomas Wayne
where I don't know if I ever needed to
see that happen like because suddenly
now all right he's meeting Thomas boy
how old was Thomas when compared to him
five years older maybe ten years older
isn't a doctor or a surgeon it's like a
weird business guy like this son of a
wealthy guy who just Minds the money and
it's an odd thing like I don't I didn't
need the Wayne's yet so but the guy who
plays offered his name I can't remember
is like really pretty good and it's like
it's it's almost like get Carter in that
way like it's kind of gritty British set
like revenge story and he's got a couple
of buddies from the war who have no
compunction against killing
[ __ ] in the street and it's
cool and at the end of the pilot
spoilers
he meets Queen Elizabeth it's like hey
you need a medal he's like fine I'll
take a medal and you're like why did he
meet Thomas Wayne and the [ __ ] Queen
in the first like it's it's odd but not
so odd that I won't watch a little bit
more because like the violence is pretty
well done and I'm a I'm a sucker for the
old ultraviolence
despite the world we live in there's
lots of fighting oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
going on oh my god you birthday [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] your TV show look at this
I haven't anywhere it's like a bad penny
this is room
it says donut friend and [ __ ] whoever
sent these definitely made a donut
friend and me what's the story on this
[ __ ] night whoo that's a lot of
[ __ ] that's look at you you went a
long way who said vegan doughnuts
weren't good me I probably did well [ __ ]
him I I know that they can donuts work
because as long as the oil is after
Supergirl in flash and all that yeah
yeah yeah you couldn't get me anymore
you know it's a guy cause vegan stuff
just it well it was but it was more
about being in Vancouver Oh
so this wouldn't really help me unless
you want to ship a bunch up to [ __ ]
bang wait so these are you vouch for
these doughnuts and they're vegan like
and you're sure they're vegan vegan they
do have ice cream there that's not vegan
but all of their doughnuts are vegan
[ __ ] a man yeah others too but I've
heard of these people you have yes I was
never gonna go cuz it's vegan
well look at those [ __ ] Donuts you
know the ones that are super [ __ ] a
static lock but I definitely want to
bite one of these so bad what do you
mean I don't have to what kind of cruel
[ __ ] is that you're like here's two
box of doughnuts don't eat them it'd be
rude not to
it's all for you Damien here we go hmm
oh my god I love sugar that is really
good I'm gonna hit one of these just cuz
I can disprove my how many this box
though I'll meet your box on that long
baby yeah tasty right oh you made a
convert man well what's your name
meg Meg yes thank you so much for these
man give it up for max you bother time
that that donut we're so much better
than the Lion King it's not even funny
[Applause]
what is egg way no way to pivot he saw
like I did see The Lion King so lie back
in the 90s I notice it was so much
better than I was
first off yes sounds like you didn't
like it not so much before we go any
step for mm-hmm we love John Pedro
I do love John we don't even I'm not
even saying we know him personally and
yet like I I think it's so weird I spent
an inordinate amount of time thinking
about Favreau because I watch Ironman
all the time
I think Ironman is a perfect film I used
to be like oh my god it's almost as good
as Star Wars I think it may actually be
just a hair better it's such a magical
[ __ ] movie that is such a strong
spine they built an entire universe on
it and it all begins with that one and
it still [ __ ] holds up and so
whenever I watching my god damn it like
without fabs you don't get Robert Downey
jr. yep without Robert Downey jr. I
don't know that I would have been as
invested in those movies like when we
watched endgame me and my wife the other
night when it ended I was just like you
know what man like I think Tony Stark is
my favorite cinematic movie character of
all time like you know we've gotten a
lot of movies with him like maybe only
James Bond has more but like I've loved
the journey of that character and I
loved the performance that Robert Downey
jr. gave and he just made me love all
those characters love Marvel even more
so I was always a DC kid so that all
comes from fabs idea that he was like
this is the guy this is your Iron Man
you do this everything else will fall
into place and they fought him I don't
know who it was that fought him
initially but ultimately like they made
Robert Downey jr. [ __ ] do a test what
are the groups screen tested you know a
lot of it was also the insurance like
insuring Downey jr. was difficult
because I've had enough histories back
of like
showing up naked in people's apartments
and like his issues with substance abuse
was was not a minor one and so getting
that dude a completion bond which means
if anything happens to him somebody will
cover the cost of making the rest of the
movie if you don't have your star
they couldn't insure him because they
couldn't count on him to [ __ ] show up
every day and [ __ ] fabs still went to
the mat for him fought tooth and nail
and convinced Feige who then convinced
paramount said this is our guy so you
sure don't want Tom Cruise no no we
think we want [ __ ] Downey so you know
that all being said we love fats and
everything these and like we love him
3000 series absolutely and the problems
with Lion King are not problems from
direction what are the problem the
problem is is that there's there's such
a difference between animation
hand-drawn 2d animation and 3d
photo-real replicas of lions is this
that thing about how I've seen a few
people comment that they don't express
emotions or something they don't and so
like a lion's face if you're doing a
photo real lions face they don't smile
they don't laugh they don't cry they're
just lines and so if you go back and
look at the original like all 2d
hand-drawn animation is about
exaggerating emotion to get you over the
fact that it's just a drawing so all of
the smiles are bigger the eyes are wider
the gestures are huge to get you to
imbue that emotion with those characters
without that stuff it's like watching a
nature documentary that's not being told
to you particularly well you know
because like I watched like Serengeti
this thing that's on I
the Discovery Channel now that's
inherited by Lupita Nyong'o and it's
cool because you can do things with that
form to impart story so that yes the
lions and tigers and bears oh my don't
actually need to act if you don't
understand what's happening until you
invest with it but if you just have like
voiceover actors trying to make these
like mannequins feel like actual
characters it's impossible question hmm
did you see his jungle book movie I did
did they suffer from the same problem a
little bit but the main character of the
jungle book is a human person so he's
excited so he's your viewpoint character
and you're reading all of his emotions
and for hiding he's afraid how can I
tell there's a line over there's a tiger
over there and a snake over there and
they see it on his face
without that it's just like this weird
parade through the jungle and like oh
it's gorgeous it's beautiful but it's
inert and so and we are bringing as an
audience so much because we know the
story like oh this is the part where
Mufasa spoiler dies and you're like this
should affect me a lot more because I
know what it is when it is in no way
near as powerful as in the cartoon even
if you get [ __ ] James Earl Jones back
which they did and he's great but it's
you're looking at like a stuffed lion
for another question yes sir is it a new
James Earl Jones performance or if they
just use the old audio it is a new James
Earl Jones performance I'm gonna save a
few bucks but just using the old audio
they could have and it would have worked
just fine yeah and like most of the
voice cast is is strong enough
especially like Billy Eichner and staff
as the Timon and Pumbaa they're having a
blast but there's just there's a
disconnect with it and there's and
there's also like I like to tell Ejiofor
a lot along a lot but there was just
something about Jeremy Irons his scar
that made him so [ __ ] delicious right
and she would tell is doing menace very
well he's doing evil very well he's
doing senior very well but he's never
petty and scar was petty
you know while he was a petty [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he wanted what he wanted I
already didn't get it to kill the [ __ ]
like that's that character and it's
another one of those movies a little bit
like like like Aladdin where it would
have benefited from you are never going
to be as good or as emotional as the
first movie so tell me tell me scholar
story make this movie about scar make
this movie about the line they've been
passed over about the [ __ ] like every
scene that he's in that we recognize
still have it in the movie just oh now
what does he do while Mufasa in [ __ ]
sim were looking up at the stars talking
about the circle of life like what is he
what is how is he occupying his time
before he commits his Hamlet and then
what does he do afterwards can I write a
scene for you please do so you want to
know what he's doing while all the movie
shit's going on yeah my cut every time
they cut to scar he's just jerking off
and it's the one time that the face is
expressive is it's a big smile and it's
unnerving enough to make you happy with
the unexpressive end so that's Evan
Smith The Lion King every time sim was
like you're a little weird aren't you
you have no idea I feel like why do you
take that calm scar look at his dick
it's just [ __ ] wrong so yeah although
that none of none of anyone's critiques
seem to be stopping that movie is it
making all the money it's doing exactly
what Disney thought it would do and make
all the money it's well the Aladdin
movie I didn't think that would make all
the money and that he had a billion
dollars so is Lion King gonna hit a
billion I think it's 400 domestic and
easily of that overseas if not a little
bit more so any minute now
so their grand design of repackaging
your childhood in shinier less emotional
ways is working gangbusters for them and
there's no reason for them to stop
they've got the Mulan trailer out they
have which luckily has humans in it it
does and what else what up what are they
what are the other live-action maybe
Little Mermaid well mermaid is Gatlin
and
another Maleficent is coming yeah like
Maleficent is the one that like seemed
to be for a moment in telling the path
they were gonna follow which was you all
know the [ __ ] Snow White story
let's tell you this other version of
that story that comes out from a
different angle and that movie made a
[ __ ] fortune and like oh so we can
just keep doing these no we're just
gonna do Beauty and the Beast the same
[ __ ] move even add a song what was
the first live-action adaptation they
did was a jungle book Cinderella
under Ella that's right yeah cuz that
what's-his-name
kenneth branagh did it and there was
nothing before that yeah and then Beauty
and the Beast was like we're doing a
full-on [ __ ] musical we're just
taking all the songs and everything that
you know and just doing it again
so yeah it's all I mean I honestly I
haven't I'm trying to think of I've seen
any of them and it's not like any sort
of like statement like [ __ ] Disney
obviously I like a lot of what they do
in step but some [ __ ] you know you just
got a limited bandwidth you don't get
around to it and you know exactly what's
gonna happen and also just like doesn't
like ring my bell you know I'm not like
oh [ __ ] I do want to see what it looks
like if it's not a cartoon I'm okay so
i-i've never I don't think I didn't see
Jungle Book I didn't see Cinderella and
then see Maleficent the Beast I didn't
see Beauty and the Beast I didn't see
Aladdin and I didn't see Lion King and
again that's not me going like I won't
see any of these [ __ ] thing it's just
not like not what I'm head make it look
Disney gets enough of my [ __ ] mind
like they can let me off the hook a few
of these [ __ ] you're batting a
thousand if not seeing any of those
movies really um oh yeah I'm seeing
Cinderella but I've seen that other
words and none of them so far been like
that was worth it
I'm Overson is interesting but snow I
was never my jam what about what would
you like to look they're doing it
whether you want it or not so what
Disney movie do you want to see
live-action Black Cauldron don't funny
meadow
yeah I guess yeah the good pole deep
cuts deep that's well I think they also
want to do a photo real version of Robin
Hood the one with the sexy foxes oh do
you not know about the sexy Fox animated
Robin Hood no oh you should go to tumblr
sometime because oh [ __ ] there are like
whole generations of women who were like
I want to [ __ ] that Fox Robin Hood
mudalali they're talking about [ __ ]
that Robin Hood all up in their hood of
lollies man wow man who divorced that
Robin Hood
I don't even [ __ ] now to be fair he's
a good-looking Fox easy piece of foxy
Fox never once I honestly I've seen that
movie like over the course of my life
let's say 15 times the animated Robin
Hood never once occurred to me that I
wanted to [ __ ] any of those characters
not a one man okay you are not his
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed as some
people are
wow so they're talking about doing a
live action version of that so wouldn't
suffer from the same thing of like
animals don't smile yeah I mean cuz even
if you notice like Pixar can absolutely
do photo real everything like they can
do tanks and planes and cars and yeah
whatever you want all of their
characters are exaggerated all those
faces are like cartoon faces because
that's how you get [ __ ] you know I've
got missile lock like no not I can't I'm
not strong enough like you get all of
those things because those big it's
amazing that you're go to pull for Pixar
was there Incredibles missile lock scene
well done like you could have one for
them you know that [ __ ] fish who lost
his [ __ ] family and [ __ ] whatever it
was called he spiked but you went for
that present that's that it makes me cry
every [ __ ] time I watched missile
lock abort abort abort
there are children aboard
no that was that was [ __ ] awesome yeah
she's like their children aboard and
they still [ __ ] sent the missiles yeah
that movie was so [ __ ] amazing good
habit so good and up till now the
greatest Fantastic Four movie we've ever
had yep but we may have in the hands of
Feige and Marvel a real Fantastic Four
movie that will actually enjoy coming up
soon but until then incredible still
holds the title yes it does
we it's ugly right into the news offer
that we got news awesome news gentlemen
this news on mark barnard he went and
found he sniffed out some news for you
give it up for Mark you got but know
[Applause]
what's happening world I am going to
cover this because it seems as if the
last couple of times I've done some news
people like I heard a rumor that this
thing happened which is not
substantiated at all by facts or
reporting but I heard it on the internet
so let's talk about it so I have one of
those oh yeah this is the best stories
those are the best stories and I think
it's not quite as rumor as it might
appear to be but the rumor is that Black
Panther 2 will have a villain a villain
that is under the sea is the villain
he's gonna fight Sebastian the crab I
mean they're both Disney so it makes
sense it is an awesome system fashion is
clearly a black crab so the way is that
it was teed up in endgame that about
something under there's a tectonic event
off of the African plate like are you
gonna do something about it as I guess
the ocean we let it happen
but McCoy a seems to have some sense
that there's something rumbling under
the ocean so it could be the Submariner
and the more that is the rumor okay now
is the bad guy the four years they
couldn't touch any more because he was
tied up elsewhere I'd always thought it
was Universal like the Hulk but it makes
more sense if he was tied up at Fox with
the Fantastic Four character or maybe he
was tied up at Universal and they made
some [ __ ] deal
where he can't be the star of his own
movie the same when the Hulk can't be
the star of a Disney movie he can only
be a supporting character excellent
point
that's a great idea like look we were
all on board for Black Panther 2 but you
know [ __ ] King versus King yeah land
King versus Sea King I'm [ __ ] all for
it and to see Marvel do the ocean you
know we've seen DC - the ocean that did
a great job but like now we get to see
Marvel's version of the ocean I'm all
for it man that's awesome yeah I hope
that rumors [ __ ] true you know and
there's there's always talk it seems
perennial that that Keanu wants to do
something in the Marvel Universe I can
see it oh my god you put him in the
little trunks and [ __ ] like that
holy [ __ ] I'm he's in good shape for six
year old man but I bet you didn't spend
a ton of time in those trunks you he's
60
where's that [ __ ] no Nate you won't
look that up I can't believe that I'm I
just 49 no I mean to be fair he was
acting in movies while I was a kid and
watching those movies like 54 it's just
like 60 it's severely rounding up all
right he's only got me by five years
that makes more sense it does so now
that makes me depressed cuz he looks
[ __ ] amazing and [ __ ] that's possible
yeah but I I would I would I would give
somebody else's left nut to see Keanu as
Namor the under uh-huh so that is that
is our rumor of the week that feels less
like rumor and more like a thing that
could actually be happening and I wonder
where did it come from where you find
this I found that because that sounds
like conjecture based on that lining
endgame but you know if that's a setup
I'm happy I remember hearing that line
and think you're like hmm but then I was
like now now today I'm like
yeah yeah now this was some [ __ ] rumor
site but because maybe also a door to
the Fantastic Four man and he's also the
door to the x-men why because he was the
first mutant oh my god you're right in
comics he was the first mutant so in the
Marvel Universe he technically could be
the first mutant as well be what a nice
little piece of synergy that is all
right I hope that's [ __ ] true that's
where it's staying alive for what else
speaking of another thing we're staying
alive for we we talked last week about
crisis on Infinite Earths yeah the big
crossover that the CW is doing through
all of the air over shows and we
mentioned that Burt Ward was coming back
as Dick Grayson in some fashion we do
know that our boy Brendan Ralph was
going to be playing the Kingdom Come
version of Superman Kevin Conroy is
going to be playing Bruce Wayne the
truest voice of Batman that has ever
been this is magical those CW shows you
know I'm in the bag from a big fan but
like what they're doing with this is
just stunning to be fair we knew about
this going back to comic-con or
something like yeah we know some people
in the world but and we know a lot more
about what they got planned and it's
just a series of [ __ ] things like
that where you're like oh my god that's
amazing oh my god that's amazing
this is the one where they blow out all
the stops yeah because this is going to
be this is arrows final season to be the
last time they can do this bigger
crossover with all the shows right and
for the first time they're bringing the
Black Lightning characters over into the
rest of the Berlanti verse during the
crisis yeah yeah that's so good
so [ __ ] I just can't Kevin calm or I get
into play Batman not just as a voice but
physically as a person is just
fanservice of the highest order
I give this many many many thumbs up
it's so [ __ ] delightful I wonder how
he felt when he got the call
I know it's like a wait I get to I mean
I'm gonna get to put on this suit well
maybe not the suit I'm sure he was just
like [ __ ] finally man 30 [ __ ] years
yeah good lord that's awesome man that
is good happy [ __ ] news
speaking of Batman you remember how Ben
Affleck was gonna make a Batman movie
yeah I'll call the Batman oh that man
that he was writing with Jeff Johnson he
was gonna direct there was word from the
cinematographer who's gonna shoot that
movie Robert Richardson who just shot
Quentin's movie yeah it's about a town
in Hollywood does him interview we was
doing press for for once about a time
and was talking about what a flex movie
was going to be and because he shot our
grow as well right shot Robert and the
other one attended by night and live by
night it was going to be Arkham Asylum
yeah
which like I'd heard that years ago I
think Geoff Johns told me that yes
that's why I was I was super excited for
that movie and the script from what I'm
saying cuz Jeff worked on it as well
it's pretty great is it yeah yeah I mean
I think that Warner Brothers ultimately
and I think with a flex agreement was
like we kind of want to go a different
way with Batman you kind of want to
young him up we kind of want to start
over and you know Matt Reeves definitely
wants to tell the younger the earlier
version of Bruce Wayne and Batman and so
I have flexure sort of badass alright
that's cool I had my - this might have
been great we never got the script
exactly way we wanted it to be but we
think we're making great guns but DC and
Warner Brothers wouldn't want it to do
what they wanted to do so I hope they
they stick with the idea sooner or later
if they're doing a young Batman I guess
they can't really do Arkham Asylum but
doing like an argument movie is so smart
you could do it low-budget doesn't have
to spend normally when they make these
movies like 100 million two hundred
million bucks but you know you're just
basically doing 10 Little Indians right
it's a haunted house picture to some
degree you know so you got your makeup
effects and stuff but generally you're
all inside and unless you're doing like
psychedelic [ __ ] with some of the
characters like scarecrow or whatever
you can probably get a pretty like you
can get a joker looking version like I
hope they made the Joker movie looks I
think it was about fifty million bucks
or so and same with Logan like take a
chance he was fifty million bucks make
an r-rated [ __ ] Batman in Arkham
Asylum yeah when we talked about that on
the podcast a while ago like there's no
reason why these movies technically need
to cost more than thirty forty fifty
million dollars it's a dude in a suit
it's all at night he's a detective like
you can absolutely make a great-looking
[ __ ] Batman movie without spending 150
million dollars on it true this so and I
also wish that there was a world in
which been and it's probably not his
call but maybe Warner Brothers did a
live reading of that script but listen
raised some [ __ ] money let's let's
make a donation to whatever foundation
we want to my video that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time or they should like a
project that will never see the light of
day let us hear it yeah yeah I'm sure
that's what they want the internet on
their dick say again like the Snyder cut
yep I'm going to step to the left of
that and hey what else we got um Marvel
and ABC it's been TCAs the television
critic association that's going on
that's going on I think it culminated it
wrapped up over the weekend but it's
been two weeks of just a bunch of like
TV Associated Press and press releases
and symposiums and panels and whatever
bunch of news to sort of come out of
that one of which is that ABC and Marvel
want to hatch another TV show and they
want it and I don't think this would be
a moral studio show think it's along the
same lines of leg agents of shield and
runaways so Marvel television Marvel
television based on a female oriented
character or a female character they
haven't said which one it is yet but
they are committed to doing that so do
you have a guess my guess is either
she-hulk is my first guess yeah
because I mean it's a [ __ ] legal
procedural like yeah giving giving
network's what they recognize and ways
for them to sell a thing they know how
to sell like if you told me you're gonna
get scandal but if Olivia Pope was also
the [ __ ] Hulk then like yeah why
would I not want that
or I guess they have to like she agents
of shield wraps up but it's his final
season yeah they did their final episode
wrapped last weekend and they still have
Marvel television cloak-and-dagger and
they still have runaways right which are
crossing over in their next season are
they really yeah that's so smart yeah
Oh what time are they both on freeform
has quite a day for mr. Hulu has a run
away that's a good idea
oh I support that that's [ __ ] cool
yeah but in the third season of both
they're gonna cross over so good but I
think MS Marvel Kamala Khan also like
right now makes a ton of [ __ ] sense
yeah totally you know makes sense too I
mean in my [ __ ] lizard brain I was
like Squirrel Girl that could work you
know who's gonna direct venom to which
they're definitely making not me wait it
is you oh [ __ ]
Andy Serkis oh right on he's been
directing like he did that Mowgli movie
mm-hmm that was on Netflix and then he
did something out Animal Kingdom I think
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I think they
wanted him because of his experience
with sort of TV and performance captured
all that stuff and because he has at
least once worked with Woody Harrelson
who is coming back as carnage so they
said that they're I mean we saw that at
the end of venom yeah that's what
they're gonna do oh it's so awesome I
remember when that character was created
and first started they put him in
storylines and whatnot and described him
as like he's a psychopathic killer it
was it was intense they showed him at a
metal concert wow that's that's how you
read psychopathy yeah he really digs the
metal and the people in the audience
they just thought it was part of the
show until they got their heads cut off
and [ __ ] yeah I look forward to that I
think that's gonna be good I I watched
venom at home and completely enjoyed it
I know you saw it in the theater or
you're like
you had issues with it but at home I
could pause it go take a [ __ ] come back
it's dead and it was totally totally fun
were you I don't think we talked about
this are you a Stephen King fan yeah
more or less
I mean not like hardcore but I've read
when I was a kid
Christine The Shining The Stand maybe
different seasons if I remember but none
of the the Richard Bach or the Bachmann
stuff right but I mean you know I've
read at a port a certain point if you
grew up in the 70s and 80s like yeah no
choice you had like Stephen King was
there before the internet was there and
yeah he was you could feel like he was
one of you or you wanted to be part of
his world rather but yeah I don't know I
mean yeah I like Stephen King why just
curious I have no news moving on you
know one of my formative like reading
experiences yes was riding the subway in
New York reading the stand oh [ __ ] yeah
which and there's the I think it's like
the second or the third chapter when the
disease starts to go and there's a scene
like on the subway house is starting to
move and it's like one person on that
subway car coughed and I'm reading the
[ __ ] book on a subway car I'm like am
I gonna [ __ ] die now great what do
you have lady CBS is making a stand
miniseries did you not know the app
channel right CBS all access yes I did
know this but the boy who did the
director Josh Boone yes Josh Boone who
did the Fault in Our Stars and they
maybe will see it maybe we won't New
Mutants
that's Friday directed the New Mutants
movie that's kind of now been lost in
the shuffle yeah but he was Steve's on
my podcast years ago talking about
wanting to do the stand and then they
announced like I don't know six months
ago or whatever that
gonna do it for CBS all access Stephen
King is writing the final episode which
is I suppose brand-new material like
it's the last chapter that we've never
read before of what happens in the stand
story oh is that right a new coach like
NJ new mom yeah yeah he's coming back to
do that just himself and that's a bunch
of casting Amber Heard is in it playing
hold on
Nadine cross a deeply conflicted woman
who feels the consequences of her
actions but it's so compelled by her
allegiance to Randall Flagg in the dark
man who's playing Randall Flagg they
haven't announced that yet and James
Marsden is playing Stu Redman so he's
your lead James Marrs and Cyclops I like
him yeah putting it in my head that's
good
yeah I like that mo Owen let's pose moon
by now the fact that Stephen King is
telling us more stance tours newsstand
story sweet man this is kind of his work
and he himself have lived long enough
where later on in life he's like oh I
can add to it
mm-hm and not in a way that would
irritate people were like don't touch
the book man but like for the miniseries
that's totally cool yeah and marketable
totally and he's also [ __ ] with the
book like there is there's multiple
versions I remember correctly he'll go
back innocent now this is the unabridged
version this is the supercut I only went
read one and it was really [ __ ] long
so when they were like there's a longer
one I'm like I'm good
do you remember I want to say it was
earlier this year I I raved and ranted
about a film called fast color yes and I
thought of you this week when I saw this
story and if you were not here for that
episode fast color is this movie that
was directed by Julia Hart and written
by Julianne and her husband Jordan
Horowitz who almost won an Oscar for her
la-la-land but was like the class act it
was like no we didn't win he was the guy
he was like no moonlight you guys won
you should come up here and get your
[ __ ] Oscars right but it is this like
it is both a story about three
generations
women who have in their lives done awful
things to each other and the the sort of
psychic and emotional tonnage that we
pass from mother to daughter from father
a son from generation to generation and
it is also the best x-men movie you
haven't seen yet because all of these
women have [ __ ] superpowers and
they're all like struggling to some
degrees with the responsibility of
having it with control over it with the
dominion of it and their place in the
world because of it right and it's a it
reminds me a lot of the Terminator
actually in that it's like very limited
special effects they shout it on a tiny
[ __ ] budget but the world building is
so smart and the script is so well done
that it sings and when it sings when you
get to that last act and when [ __ ]
really starts to happen it's phenomenal
and nobody saw the movie because it
opened the week before Avengers end game
in like 26 theaters and it just got it
debuted sanely well of South by
Southwest and then was dropped by
Lionsgate at the end of the day and then
the world got Avengers crazy and then
nobody [ __ ] talked about it except
for me like a lunatic on Twitter I
remember and also here you give it a big
review it still remains in my top 10 of
the year a lock like no matter what else
they see it is for sure there to be on
that list
but then something some good news some
good news happen where Amazon and and
Viola Davis and her company decided that
hey you know what let's make this a TV
show and owned a series they're doing a
series they're doing a fast color TV
show that now will they is it spinoff
from the movie or they'll just retell
the movie in the show um if I had to
guess it will just be like chapter 2 and
let's get into the the the real story
I'm sure there's gonna be a little bit
of kind of rehashing the events of the
film but Hart and Horowitz are gonna
write and direct the pilot they are
looking for you know there there are
other pieces and they were the
components and they're gonna make a
[ __ ] TV show which casts coming back
her now they don't know yet I hope so
because Google and bought the raw can do
no wrong it was great she's phenomenal
okay ready to sont is amazing
that is a good piece of news somebody
recognized clever story no let's keep
going yeah we can do that he's doing it
uh Amazon good for them man
they got the boys as well where I got
the boys there and Lord of the Rings and
Wheel of Time Lord of the Rings they
haven't trailered yet or anything right
they haven't even started they they
announced like a single piece of casting
and it's somebody that I've never heard
of before right
but uh but yeah no [ __ ] they're
spending all the money on all of the big
things because they realize that we're
in an arms race right now like streaming
TV is a [ __ ] gun show yeah and who's
got the biggest guns
it's the cola wars all over them it's
VHS and Betamax
it truly is so yeah I'm super excited
for that did you well you almost know
you did play D&D once I listened to a
podcast where you play D&D once I did
and also played it on relics and
rarities mmm online this show nice there
they've been trying to make a movie of f
dungeon dragon the actual property the
actual property here it comes
there's got it though now I want to like
tease this [ __ ] out for though they've
been trying to make it for a while there
was a little bit of a heat bloom on it
about five years ago and then the
Warcraft movie came out that like set it
back a little bit but now you know who's
who's gonna direct this movie let me
think
Dungeons & Dragons Andy Serkis
no you might think
no it's John Francis daley and Jonathan
Goldstein who wrote homecoming and who
directed game night
wait what so the guys that there are two
directors of game night yes that day as
a team and they wrote spider-man
homecoming yes they were the two writers
who didn't come back before for far from
home they were also going to do the
flash movie for a hot minute
yeah everybody in their grandmother was
going to do the flash movie yeah
they're now doing Dungeons & Dragons
right and I like those guys a game night
if you haven't seen it is phenomenal
it's really good like it's it is Eve
Corral right um no it was named [ __ ]
man yes Jason I was gonna say Michael
Bluth but yes Jason Bateman it's it's
the other one
yes now it's him and you know [ __ ]
other people but it's this super great
little Adam McAdams McAdams it's a very
smart like adult comedy that's just it's
whip-crack smart the plot just moves
like a freight train and it finds real
moments for real humor in there and like
you get why those guys are now that
thing right you get a lot of the humor
from homecoming comes from them and they
seem to have an aptitude for directions
so yeah [ __ ] it give them a big ass I
just re-watched homecoming on the flight
back from Jersey [ __ ] that movie really
works on your homecoming from New Jersey
I had truly and and that what I liked
didn't realize that as I was watching it
cuz time folds in on itself that was a
couple years back now yeah cuz Spiderman
was then in infinity war and then a year
later end game so that has to be like at
least maybe two unit before that in
[ __ ] Civil War oh my god you're right
so it was oh wait first Civil War but
then spider-man far from home happened
home coming up homecoming happened and
then infinity war right and end game so
maybe it's only done like two years it
felt like much longer or shorter
actually is that it oh we got one last
little thing okay
were you a fan of event horizon the
movie live I'm a fan of one sequence in
event horizon when they show like the
[ __ ] madness like that [ __ ] line I
have the people going apeshit that still
to this day impresses the [ __ ] out of me
the rest of the movie I don't remember
that much about it had Sam Neill in it
Samuel and Lawrence fish Laurence
Fishburne Armour yeah
like we're on a deep space machine and
we hit a black hole and you know what to
the other side of a black hole hell hell
that was kind of the idea yeah because
sure that's where that is hell in space
there they're also developing that as a
TV show that's gonna be a show as well
yeah you know where Amazon are you
kidding me
goddamn man they're just buying
everything the IP war isn't it everyone
wants something that somebody knows and
[ __ ] yeah whether they have any like
good feelings about it or not like they
might recognize that name I know man if
they could get a [ __ ] event horizon
show set up at Amazon I gotta go in
there and be like hey man clerks
that's [ __ ] dope is that all the news
that is all the news Merida is give it
up for mark give me the news all right
now ladies and gentlemen we get to the
Q&A portion of the show man although I
just keep looking at those doughnuts
curse you thanks ma'am I'm totally
eating those tomorrow like two o'clock
they'll probably keep right they will
mmm [ __ ] I can't wait all right so the
Q&A portion of the show ladies and
gentlemen as part of the show people
seem to like not like they don't like
the other parts but this is the part
that they get to engage with men we ask
that you could anybody that Jacy picks
can pick three people if you're a
question ask her and we dig your
question you're gonna win some free
tickets first off we got tickets of
course from our good friends at 40x
Deacon got us some tickets once again
the 40x folks give you two tickets to
where's you go see it here at LA live
correct if you've never seen a movie in
40x
the [ __ ] is your problem this will be a
way to do it for free man it's a
wonderful experience with a chair that
shakes in a room that stinks and shit's
shot in your face and whatnot it's like
being I I can't wait till 40x does porn
[ __ ] oh
it's gonna be quite the experience but
the Gallagher concert yes for you old
people you know for the young people
he used to smash watermelons on stage
and so the first like five rows had to
be covered with plastic otherwise you'd
have watermelon goo all over people
would bring the plastic yes reference
from 1978 always reminds me of early
Showtime because he was like meeting
residents all right
the other ticket we got for you on top
of that you're gonna get two tickets
that but then you're also gonna get two
tickets do tickets - tickets - it's the
20th anniversary of the matrix ladies
and gentlemen and because of that the
good one the one we all liked and
because of that I like tamal too and
because of that it's where's the plan
you swing at The Wiltern they're shown
it at the [ __ ] will turn so we got
two tickets for you to go see that The
Wiltern winter's day August 8th 7 p.m.
so that's like this Thursday that's you
two days two days we got two days to
plan your [ __ ] [ __ ] those tickets
will be yours yes you guys can't go home
if you want to go see in the matrix
you're done yet when do you guys leave
Thursday so he's got room in his house
stuff you can say in the possibly yeah
you could stay at my place of course as
you know we're good
alright so there it is man we JC's gonna
pick people ask questions the only thing
we ask ladies and gentlemen is that the
questions are questions that both of us
can answer it so that way we get a
little chitchat going
that being said JC the barkeep at this
fine establishment he's picked somebody
stuck a mic in their hand that man is at
the wall and white what's your name
Jeremy Jeremy yes everyone give it up
for Jeremy
thank you which God first captain okay
so picture this take any animation
series any and you can take that main
character and switch it with any Marvel
Universe character so for example let's
take Optimus Prime from the Transformers
Universe and switch them with say the
Hulk from The Avengers or the whole from
the hoax reality and then put the Hulk
in the transformer world which
characters would you take and as a kind
of a follow-up if you could be any
cartoon character who would you be
Wow as an example I'm Wiley coyote he's
a genius never gives up alright let's
let's do there's a lot to think about
Jeremy yeah like that's not some [ __ ]
amateur like 101 question how about
let's start with who I'd be in cartoons
first which cartoon character would you
like to be Bugs Bunny hands-down Bugs
Bunny never got [ __ ] beat ever in
every cartoon I've ever watched he
always [ __ ] won he was always the
most clever [ __ ] in the room
even when [ __ ] was looking dark he could
spin it and whatnot he could [ __ ]
sing opera
yeah Bugs Bunny man [ __ ] I've tried
to live my life like Bugs Bunny so I'm
gonna see that yep right totally
but I've wound up being Daffy more often
than not what character would you want
to be ah I think I got a ghost Snoopy
oh I almost said Snoopy to that I was
like why would I want to be stupid why
do you want to be stupid because I think
Snoopy is never flummoxed he he always
knows kind of what he's about what he
wants to do he knows how to make [ __ ]
Thanksgiving dinner of like toast and
candy and popcorn so that's cool that's
true um and he is he's an adventurer
soul even if those adventures are only
in his mind so yeah I think I go Snoopy
he hasn't talked though I know I expect
the unit takes nearly
okay so the part of your collection of
it yeah is so I get the cartoon
character for one show stick them into
Marvel Universe and then stick the
Marvel character into the other show so
for example Hong Kong Phooey
in shang-chi the master of Kung Fu yes
yes
thank God it didn't nail it oh man
alright T'Challa okay lion-o or I mean
Panthro would probably be the more
direct lift but like Panthro is not the
[ __ ] King I think that's a better
choice she made the right choice alright
that's [ __ ] good
- satisfying answers very one very
excellent question give it up for me one
[Applause]
[Music]
pleasure man [ __ ] underdog and Rocket
Raccoon good man but underdog does drugs
can't have that man hello what's your
name my name is Alison Alison everyone
give it up for Alison please everybody
sing that song to you when they hear
your name who sings that Elvis got
stolen
really I've never heard of that song Wow
pick a girl's name you'll find it what
can we do for you I don't know it's good
so thinking about all of the new
platforms that we have available to us
now thinking about the new productions
that's happening in movies now pushing
that forward 20 50 years what franchise
would you want to see rebooted for the
next generation like 20 years down 50
years down with all of that technology
that will be available then which one
would you want to see redone look I
would choose the [ __ ] mark based on
what I've just seen over the last 10
years Marvel Cinematic Universe I choose
that every time but if we're talking 50
years down the line I would imagine the
technology as to the point where they
just like stick something in your ear
and you're in the [ __ ] movie as well
so that would be fantastic with no
stakes right you can't really die or
something like that I would like to be
an end game you know
like being it not like the star of it
but like you know you put it in your ear
and suddenly the movies happening around
you and [ __ ] so you could be like run
cap she'll like it what about you
what franchise and I like from today
right [ __ ] I Tron I mean I I still think
we haven't gotten the Tron we deserve
like I like Tron Legacy fine did you
ever stop to think maybe you did get the
Tron you deserve you just not a good boy
but it's a good pole man that's that's
dope I think I do some cool [ __ ] you can
do some super cool [ __ ] like whatever
future-tech downloadable content
straight into your cerebral cortex world
we live in but the idea of being one
with the information that you consume in
an era in which we're consuming
information at a frightening rate and
we're consuming information ways you
never previously thought possible it
feels like there's there's just nothing
but possibility with some electron thank
you very much
I think we should go we should go deeper
all right
Muppets because in the future they're
not puppets they're just living things
like there's a frog that talks there's a
pig that he dates like it's a horror
movie yes
in a world where people like these
live-action remakes of the cartoons like
Lion King and [ __ ] well most people like
him on everybody but I could see that
coming to pass man all right so you want
one more yeah good okay okay okay okay
lethal weapon no oh I thought that was
your joke Pesci from lethal weapon okay
let's drive through the a-team there is
always room or should be in the world
for a bunch of criminals who if you can
find them maybe you can hire [ __ ]
song Mike post wanted all this [ __ ]
money's worth like in the old age home
the motion picture resting home guys we
need a theme song for the a-team I know
what a call if you can find them he died
mid eighties that was a great question
give it up version gets ticket
then come get your stub pleasure will do
the lefty here we go alright last
question
JC or final questions go what's your
name
Alex Alex everybody difficult question
before my question do you recognize this
particular bat insignia I mean it looks
familiar
so this is the James Gordon Batman like
from the super-heavy Ark with Scott
Snyder and so my question is kind of
related to that so like with spider-man
into the spider versus with Miles
Morales kind of like anyone can wear the
mask and James Gordon can add like a
similar arc with Batman but if you guys
could put the mask of any hero unto a
new character which one do you think you
guys would want to you know ream ask put
a fresh face under that okay well done
alright let's think man hmm how about
here make it easier on us give us the
characters and you could pick five six
because there's two of us can't be
divided by to pick six and we'll tell
you who to remaster Munger okay six
characters yeah you can start with
Batman for sure
oh man you toss it out on me I know I'm
like [ __ ] you you answer my question
all right start with Batman because the
Batman okay that means serving a five
more that Manso characters from within
that universe who could be under the
mask or just if you want a remaster like
like they've done with like with the
Hulk I don't think anybody would have
thought Amadeus Cho would have become
the new like the Hulk for an in terms
right something like that right fair
enough
so like you know my uncle Rodney I could
say is Batman
which is weird because he's like 70
years old and black but sure that that's
the hero we deserve I would say Harvey
Dent
alright dent is under the masses under
the mask that's good
that's [ __ ] good maybe it saves his
sanity you know about justice and maybe
the mask is a little different so it
covers my you know I'm saying that's
sweet so that one okay alright for
Batman who gets to wear two Cal Selina
Kyle I'm saying she's been his life
forever what not Catwoman cat me yeah
let's think on all right so we got two
bad men just to Batman now you got five
more characters to go okay I think one
of the easier ones like the ring slinger
like Green Lantern if you had to toss
that ring on to somebody hopeful in the
DC Universe who might you put it on
Green Lantern snap her car he hung out
with the [ __ ] Justice League and [ __ ]
he was there buddy and whatnot that
their their acolyte if you will let him
he certainly knows he's been around here
owes his whole career let him become
hero yeah a lantern Lantern Lois Lane as
a Green Lantern yeah that's good I think
she's got a pretty good bead on the
best and the worst of what humanity can
offer and should be [ __ ] badass all
right four more to go for morning I like
we made it like harder for him than it
deserves it do some [ __ ] work buddy
no tickets I explained it to come up
here throw out a question is Stan here
yes it'd make me work I like but I
appreciate that
man I had one in mind oh yeah that would
be a good one dc's as well yeah who gets
the code who gets the new so Ezreal as
your Oh Batman thank you what was your
gist Azrael sort of basra thanks Kyle
Azrael like sort of Azurill Azurill it's
a John Mark whatever his name was Ron
Paul or Daly's on marginal Valley yes
Paul Gosselaar I believe that was John
Paul valet John Paul valéry who would be
the new Azrael Damian if he was still
around yeah
Lucius Fox oh wow or just Morgan Freeman
just like Morgan Freeman that's a much
lucious as Morgan Freeman all right
Terry Moore hey let's get it let's get a
new cap Kappas caps shield can go to a
lot of different people it's kind of the
Falcon gone to Bucky who would you put
the shield on to next clue could be cab
Peggy Carter I I think you're gonna get
that wish what if they're gonna do what
if Carter was Captain America Howard
Stark
yeah especially like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe version of hell yeah
John Slattery is oh it's my favorite
scene in the movie so [ __ ] beautiful
when he like right before he leaves his
dad and [ __ ] and he's just like you know
he's like my dad you know
never there wasn't anything he couldn't
you know explain with the belt and he's
just like I used to think my dad was
hard on me and now looking back I just
remember the good stuff I put up a
[ __ ] tweet or something like about
and I was watching endgame and I said a
moment where you know Howard tells his
son he's like I hope it's a girl because
he's talking about his wife being
pregnant less a chance that she'll grow
up to be just like me and then Tony says
what would be so bad about that
and then Howard says let's just say the
you know what is it the greater good has
never outweighed my own self-interest
then they cut to Tony any kind of clocks
it it's no way on earth that line is not
meant to be there to spur him in the
third act correct yeah
yes so I said in my tweet I was like
this is Tony finally learning to lay
down on the wire which is something that
they talked about in the Avengers when
Captain America was like you you'd be
the guy to lay down a wire let your
buddy go over it man and Iron Man is
like I think I cut the water like he was
always trying to find like you know
where so I felt like this is it this is
like that was the moment where he
learned to lay down on the wire and then
some hardcore [ __ ] Tony Stark fans
got so shitty with me on Twitter and
told me like your read of this is
[ __ ] idiotic
and and they they said like they saw a
different version of those movies than I
did they said that Howard was abusive
and they listed things that Tony has
said over the movies but I never heard
abusive I heard like you know because he
was like he was cold he never told me
love me bubble blah [ __ ] like that but I
never got the fact that like he was
slapping his kid around or
thing like that by any stretch of the
imagination he's a little distant this
person had a read of it where they were
like Howard Stark was a piece of [ __ ]
who [ __ ] abused his kid he [ __ ]
eating trying to impress this [ __ ]
guy at all I'm like hi I don't know I'm
a writer and like I know writers and
nobody puts a [ __ ] moment into a
movie for no reason whatsoever so that
moment when he's sitting there talking
to him and later on and he's just like
he he goes I used to think he was hard
on me but now all I remember are the
good good things and he said he did drop
the occasional Pearl mm-hmm and he goes
like what and he goes no amount of money
ever bought a single second of time and
then Howard goes like he says smart guy
and then Tony goes he did his best so
[ __ ] beautiful so beautiful because
Tony got to have this kind of like
wrap-up moment without being mawkish
like he honored the character arc of
Tony Stark even though he was sitting
there hugging his dad he it was more
sense of closure and not like I'm
weeping and [ __ ] like that and he had
grown as an adult like right before he
left this world I'm gonna get so
emotional he didn't really die it's a
movie but
right before he left he got that closure
which you know is he had dad issues in
every one of those [ __ ] movies there
was always a kind of reference to Howard
and stuff he had reached a maturity
level where he understood that he'd been
incorrect his whole life as to like my
dad was so [ __ ] hard on me he got to
a place where he goes I get it I'm a dad
now oh I [ __ ] love that it's so quiet
such a beautiful mama and the movies
full of like big moments a memorable
[ __ ] but that to me was the absolute
[ __ ] heart and soul of that movie and
[ __ ] that person on the internet did he
did learn to [ __ ] lay down on the
wire because of his dad I maintain it
now I'm gonna ask Markus and McFeely
they'll [ __ ] tell well you should you
should have like a macro setup on your
keyboard that just says [ __ ] that person
on the internet just send it out okay
because I feel like that would come in
good in good stead yeah in many
occasions but the Internet
it's so funny like like you're reading
of this is [ __ ] ignorant like what
how how many different ways can you read
and gay man like anyway where were we
I'm on my last two I'll pick a pair but
it's gonna be kind of an awkward one so
mu nobody Jason we hang out a lot
together we talked a lot of comics but
we kind of see each other as like a Blue
Beetle to boost your gold team up
although I'm kind of the dumbass and
he's a smart one but I like beetle
better he never likes gold better so if
you guys had to put there costing
booster and Blue Beetle with Lucy Blue
Beetle yeah alright Booster Gold
somebody else from the DC Universe well
since we're playing around and [ __ ]
Justice League you know international
territory like McGuire type Justice
League
I'll take Guy Gardner as has Booster
Gold and I will take Bruce Wayne as Ted
Kord as the Blue Beetle
so they can still keep fighting like one
of my favorite moments in comic book
history was when Batman takes out Guy
Gardner with one punch oh my god still
works to this day such a great story
that's my to you deeper cut
I think Cain and Abel
holy [ __ ] from house of secrets and
mysteries yeah Wow Cain and Abel Wow
original bickering fighting probably
want to kill each other and do do one
over and over and over again
can't get that mark out so yeah Cain and
Abel wow that's a deep cuts pull man
that's classy pull that's kind of pull
like my pole is wizard would like it
comment would like your pull man as
class I'm smudging to prove what a great
[ __ ] question yielded some funds [ __ ]
give it up for me once very much thank
you Frank oh my god we've got no more
news we've got no more tickets that
means we got no more show at least we
got all these donut do have a [ __ ] ton
of doughnuts thank you so much ladies
and gentlemen you have a good time this
evening
I can't thank you enough for coming out
and supporting the show man but there
ain't no show without this dude right
here give it up for the great Marc
Bernardo and that is fat man beyond for
this week I'm Kevin Smith I'm upping our
tune in next time same bat time same bat
Channel are we doing a show next week we
are doing a show next come see the show
next week right area do we have a show
the week after that we have consecutive
Tuesday's we've got two more shows
coming up on the next two Tuesday's
tickets at sea spots so come see us same
fad time same fat channel spot cast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith for the
good of all kreega night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you